in my last video we explored the story
of morgot the omen king of lindell but
to get the full picture of the regal
omen there is another we have to learn
about one who represents the other path
that morgot could have taken instead of
defending the urgery and renouncing his
blood morgot could have festered given
himself to his blood's curse and swore
revenge on an unjust world at the end of
this path of darkness is the key to
fully understand morgot it is another
omen born of the same circumstances it
is his twin moog lord of blood
but i'm not going to talk about moog
right now because he deserves a whole
another video instead i want to look at
a core aspect important to the stories
of both morgot and moog i want to look
at the curse of the omen where it comes
from and what it can tell us about the
lands between i spoke a bit about the
omen in my last video how they are born
outside of grace and are subsequently
enslaved the common omen have their
horns cut off and are used as soldiers
in the order's armies the royal omen are
allowed to keep their horns but they are
sequestered into the sewers of the royal
capital the two oman demigods morgot and
moog were both originally locked away as
we read from their shackles but they
broke free and followed different paths
so far we don't know what specifically
causes an omen to be born other than by
some sort of spurning by the greater
will or urgery but it seems any parents
can give birth to omen since even the
parents of the demigod twins were able
to have a non-omen child too queen
merica and godfrey first eldon lord had
omen twins but also a non-omen in godwin
the omen are a seeming mystery but we
can learn more about them if we
investigate the crucible the crucible is
an elusive entity in eldon ring many if
not most players probably won't be able
to say anything certain about it after a
playthrough but there are a few hints
and descriptions throughout the world
that pull back the current the first and
most relevant to our omen discussion is
the set of crucible talismans a group of
three talismans that each bear the name
of the crucible along with an attribute
not feather and scale each of these are
found in an environment relating to the
omen whether that be dropped by an omen
killer located in the omen sewers or
guarded by an actual omen they
respectively read a talisman fashioned
from a bony knot scale or feathers that
embodies the aspects of various
creatures said to have grown on the
human body long ago a vestige of the
crucible of primordial life born
partially of devolution it was
considered a signifier of the divine in
ancient times but is now increasingly
disdained as an impurity as civilization
has advanced
so it sounds like the crucible is some
entity of life that existed long ago
before the current age
and its vestiges were viewed as divine
but are now seen as impure we find a
similar description of the crucible that
goes into more detail in the aspects of
the crucible incantations which read
this is a manifestation of the erd
tree's primal vital energies an aspect
of the primordial crucible where all
life was once blended together the
crucible here sounds like a previous
version or stage of the world and life
life used to be in one contiguous blend
if you've watched my ending videos you
might pick up that this sounds fairly
similar to the three fingers description
of the one great an entity that all life
existed in before divisions or
individuals this is what we achieve in
the lord of frenzied flame ending
melting everything back into one with
the chaos flame so the crucible could be
something like the one great a time when
all life was in one big hodgepodge
without individual beings or lives and
souls it could even be the one great
but before committing to that we have
one more description to look at the
crucible incantations are wielded by
crucible knights their armor tells
another aspect of the story reading
armor of the crucible knights who served
godfrey the first elden lord holds the
power of the crucible of life the
primordial form of the urgery this
doesn't necessarily contradict anything
said so far but it tells us that
whatever the crucible was it served as
the base or original form of the erd
tree perhaps the crucible transformed
into the urge tree over time due to the
influence of the greater will and maybe
the elden beast and or elden rank this
would work with the idea of the frenzied
flame and three fingers blaming the
greater will for ruining the one great
by introducing individuals and divisions
in any case as the crucible progressed
over time life seems to have become more
individualized if all life was once
blended together it now seems to not be
even long ago in the ancient times
referred to by the crucible talismans
there was individual life because that
life would somehow devolve and bear an
aspect of the crucible and such a sign
was considered a mark of divinity we see
another case of individuals interacting
with the crucible in the misbegotten the
winged humanoids treated as slaves
throughout the lands between their ashes
read the misbegotten are held to be a
punishment for making contact with the
crucible and from birth they are treated
as slaves or worse the misbegotten were
able to make some form of contact with
the crucible perhaps their wings and
feathers are vestiges as discussed by
the feather talisman the history and
progression of the crucible seems to be
a complex one originally subsuming all
of life but then existing alongside life
it even somehow imparted its vestiges
onto living individuals with those
individuals being seen as signs of
divinity
with all this in mind we can finally
return to our omen and come to a
slightly clearer understanding it seems
that all signs point to the omen bearing
a mark or vestige of the crucible
remember that anyone can give birth to
an omen and the crucible talismans state
that their vestiges which took the form
of things like feathers scales and horns
body knots basically count as horns to
me are said to have grown on the human
body long ago
so omen seem like humans born with the
vestiges of the crucible maybe something
like this was the case with the
misbegotten and some other creatures too
we can also read the ashes of perfumer
tricia who was a healer who dedicated
her efforts to treating misbegotten omen
and all those seen as impure the omen
misbegotten and others are seen as
impure likely because of their
connection with the crucible in an
ancient time the omen likely would have
been regarded as divine or at least
bearing signs of divinity but in the
modern world of the lands between they
are enslaved and subjugated we see
conclusively that marks of the crucible
are considered impure by the current
world maybe as the greater will pushed
the world away from the crucible's
original state it and its followers grew
to have some animosity for the crucible
and its influence the modern order has
treated the omen and others marked by
the crucible as demons using them for
their strength but torturing and
enslaving them otherwise
this treatment of the crucible as impure
finds an interesting inflection point in
the crucible knights these are knights
that serve godfrey and practice
incantations of the crucible and a quick
aside each of the incantations and magic
of the knights seem to correspond to the
features of the talismans the horns are
like the omen the fire breath is like
the scaled lizards wings for feathers
and so on perhaps the knights began
their practice long ago and a time
before there was significant animosity
towards the crucible but with godfrey
banished they were also moved out of the
way the ones we come across in game are
mostly pushed off to the side whether
they be in ever jails at the bottom of
graves fighting with misbegottens or
full-blown heretics the crucible knights
which were legendary knights of old are
not being utilized or honored by the
order it seems plausible that their
relationship with the crucible is the
reason
now we can look once more at our omen
with renewed understanding they serve as
a prime example of the history of the
lands between
in them we can see traces of the past
form of life the crucible that which was
to become the erd tree in an ancient
time after the crucible began its
progression perhaps at the behest of the
greater will the omen and those like
them who showed signs of the crucible
were regarded as divine a sharp contrast
to the state we see them in now
ostracized and imprisoned things likely
only got worse with the shattering and
the decay of the order perhaps omen were
not always blighted by so many horns or
other growths maybe the crucible's
vestiges used to appear more like the
forms we see crucible knights take with
their incantations slightly more uniform
growths that do not get in the way so
much like all the horns marring the eyes
of the twins
maybe there was a balance to be had
between the crucible's original state of
life as one big soup and the complete
subjugation of the crucible by the
greater will and the order i'm inclined
to think so since both moog and morget
the omen demigods put up guards against
the tarnished getting to the frenzied
flame there is nothing in the game that
shows morgot and moog working together
except for this one instance where moog
puts up an apparition and morgot puts a
seal both in an effort to prevent the
player from the frenzied flame ending
where the world would maybe return to a
crucible-like state melted into one i
think this is decent evidence that a
complete return to the crucible is not a
desirable goal and obviously the horrid
treatment of the omen misbegotten and so
many others by the order is not ideal
either as i've been saying a direction
toward balance more in tune with the
crucible and its vestiges but not all
the way to where life becomes
unrecognizable seems to be the best
outcome for everyone and we could get
into a discussion about which ending
best serves this purpose but i'm pretty
sure that would just start a few flame
wars in the comments besides i already
made my stance on that clear in another
video the story of the omen is a
revealing one for much of what is
beneath the surface of the main story of
eldon rank their plate and placement
gives us a good advantage to see into
the past understand the present and
maybe see what's best for the future
with this knowledge we can have an even
better understanding of morgot and we're
more ready to learn about moog there is
of course more to discuss on this topic
i really think there is a tie-in to the
crucible and the urge tree with the
ancestral spirit but we can wait till a
proper moog discussion for that after
all they're in the same underground zone
if you've enjoyed this exploration into
omen lore consider subscribing to the
channel it lets me know that people are
interested in the content and wants to
see more like i said i'm looking to do
moog next and plenty more individual
demigods and other characters but that
might be in a bit since i'll be with
family for the holidays i tried to get
this video out fast so i hope you all
feel the quality didn't dip too much
also i don't have a good idea why
morgot's horn disappear when he dies a
lot of comments from my previous video
were asking that question it probably
has something to do with his complicated
relationship with the erd tree and being
grace given despite being an omen with
vestiges of the crucible if i had to
guess it's some interplay of these
conflicting forces that causes that
unique circumstance that we see happen
with that i hope you enjoyed watching
and feel free to leave a comment about
your thoughts on the omen and the
crucible and whether or not you like
these kinds of videos that delve more
into the world of the lands between than
a specific demigod i'm gonna do more of
the demigods and characters but if
people enjoy these kinds of videos i'm
happy to do more lore like this since it
is interesting to get into the deep
underpinnings of the story and the world
that really deep lore like the crucible
and the start of life and kind of what i
did in the outer gods video
so with that thanks for spending time in
this video bye